un autre projet allant à l'envers de la
situation d'aménagement du territoire
actuel vient d'être rendu public il
émane de la DATAR la délégation
interministériel à l'aménagement du
territoire c'est un scénario pour 2020
qui redécouperait ainsi totalement le
territoire français en six grands
ensembles naturel cela n'est pas du goût
d'une grande partie des élus régionaux
voyez le reportage de Jeff vtimbert avec
Bernard
RET dans 20 ans la France pourrait être
ceci au centre un grand vide et des
régions qui regardent vers ailleurs ou
bien alors cela Paris toutpuissant et le
reste de l'hexagone à moins que la
France de 2020 n'est finalement cette
allure un rien anarchique toutes ces
cartes c'est la datard qui les a imaginé
mais en réalité la délégation à
l'aménagement du territoire a un autre
scénario sont préféré en langage de
technocrate cela s'appelle le
polycentrisme six grandes régions pour
éviter entre autres que les villes
moyennes ne dépérissent Amien
SaintQuentin reince 3 Chalon voitour le
et camp si on n'y prend pas garde Paris
va attirer énormément les gens vont
venir vivre dans des HLM dans des
chambes V et toutes ces belles villes
légendair splendid seront abandonné par
leurs habitants c'est quand même idiot
de nouvelles entités administrativ et
des villes organisées en réseau ce
serait donc la France idéale de demain
l'ennui c'est que les acteurs de la
France d'aujourd'hui celle des 22 région
désirent garder leur pouvoir ils ne
veulent donc pas entendre parler de ces
super régions fait région 10 millions
d'habitants c'est la puissance et à ce
moment-l qu'est-ce qui se passe on est
dans l'Europe des régions on est à
l'allemande quelquefois à l'espagnool
c'està-dire des grandes régions
fédérales qui ont le pouvoir législatif
et qui naturellement à un moment ou un
autre jouent contre l'État l'argument
est évidemment porteur au moment où le
projet pour la Corse fait craindre à
certains le démantellement de l'État
naation au moment aussi où une
commission présidée par Pierre montroi
réfléchit à une nouvelle
décentralisation pourtant c'est promis
on ne touchera pas à l'essentiel pouvoir
de l'État centr en France remonte si
loin dans l'histoire il a touché
tellement les Français fctionnaire le
pouvoir central luimême bien entendu que
la France restera un pays centralisé la
DAT en tout cas une certitude il faut
aujourd'hui simplifier l'organisation de
la France et d'abord pour des raisons
économiques exemple éloquant un chef
d'entreprise américain voulait
s'installer dans le Sud-Ouest le lundi
matin c'était le le préfet de région qui
disait je dirige le la région le le
mardi matin c'était le préfet de
département le mercredi c'était le
président de la région le jeudi c'était
le président du conseil général et le
vendredi c'était le maire de la ville et
pendant 4 semaines il a eu droit à ce
festival et au bout d'un mois il a dit
je pars donnez-moi toutes les primes que
vous voulez je ne comprends rien qui
fait quoi dans ce pays la tradition à la
vie dure avant que la France des cantons
des régions des départements celle qu'on
enseignait déjà il y a 50 ans à l'école
primaire ne s'efface devant cette
france-l il écoulera sans doute
plusieurs
décennies